so bitcoin doesn't have a lot of utility
right we can argue about strike we can
argue about the lightning network you
can tell me all you want about el
salvador but el salvador has to buy
their bitcoin in dollars mark cuban is
an american billionaire entrepreneur and
television personality he is also the
owner of the professional nba basketball
team the dallas mavericks he is one of
the american billionaires that have
declared their love for cryptocurrencies
and other digital assets in a recent
interview cuban explains that he
believes ethereum and polygon have
better prospects than bitcoin while
bitcoin has some redeeming qualities
cuban says it does not come close to the
features and use cases that are
available in the ethereum and polygon
network welcome to savvy finance in this
video we examine billionaire mark
cuban's outlook on everything from
bitcoin to nft decentralized finance and
gold he outlines the advantages and
shortcomings of each asset category but
seems to have a soft spot for defy
ethereum and polygon if you would like
to delve into the mind of this
billionaire entrepreneur ensure you
don't miss any part of this video
also remember to give this video a
thumbs up and enjoy the video unlike
other billionaires like bill miller and
michael saylor who continuously show
their partiality for bitcoin mark
cuban's activities in the digital asset
space are quite extensive while stating
that bitcoin has some great qualities he
explains that it is not special unlike
ethereum and polygon which have greater
prospects cuban also has a partiality
for non-fungible tokens
in fact nft led the billionaire to the
digital asset space after he minted one
in 2021 cuban says he found it quite
unbelievable that he sold it and also
earned royalties on secondary sales this
event sold cuban on smart contracts and
every other aspect of the space here is
mark cuban on his journey to nft and
smart contracts i'm a tech geek and so i
try to learn about new technologies and
i was always up to speed on blockchain
but i never really spent any time with
smart contracts and so i decided to mint
some nfts i remember that you know and
they sold which was shocking to me but
um it got me understanding how smart
contracts worked and in particular
when i meant it and it started asking me
for royalties and i'm like i sounded
like kevin right royalties
um tell me more and so then it finally
dawned on me that you know a smart
contract on a chain is universal and
standard and the royalties that can be
applied there um changed the game in
terms of collectibles and digital
digital file sales and
that
pursuing it from that side of it
was
groundbreaking to me and that really got
me excited the shark tank investor also
talks about defy bitcoin and gold which
he seems to prefer in the particular
order he explains that he enjoys the
flexibility and freedom he gets with
decentralized finance applications
though the industry is not without its
pitfalls
for bitcoin cubans sees it as a great
store of value one that is far better
than gold
however the mavericks owner emphatically
states that bitcoin is not a hedge
against inflation human believes this is
just a tactic that bitcoin maximalists
use to lure investors into the space
listen to cuban's thoughts on bitcoin
gold and defy as well as his favorite
defy projects
bitcoin is not a hedge to inflation
there's no world no lifetime no
circumstances ever is bitcoin ahead of
it they're not correlated to the money
system it's a great narrative for
selling bitcoin but there's no
correlation there whatsoever i mean just
look at recently right inflation keeps
on going up bitcoin go down you know you
don't see when interest and actually
when interest rates go up along with
inflation it becomes more expensive for
people to buy bitcoin and so it actually
puts a lid on the price of bitcoin but
isn't that just part of the adoption
cycle i mean you're taking inflation
over a period of time people take
bitcoin over a period of time inflation
goes up bitcoin goes that's supply and
demand that's the okay supply and demand
is undefeated right as long as you get
more demand and less supply the price is
going to go up but look at gold right
they talk about gold as a hedge to
inflation gold's not a hedge to
inflation gold isn't a hedge to anything
right it's just a store of value that is
not even a very efficient store of value
bitcoins are more efficient better store
value than gold there's like 10 trillion
dollars in people who own gold in one
form or another that's a market for
bitcoin to go after and that and just
other people looking for store values
makes it you know a legit investment and
that's why i own it but the whole idea
that it's a score of that it's a hedge
against inflation is ridiculous keep i
like because look i can borrow money in
30 seconds but
i've got money in the bank and i want to
borrow money against it i got to call
bankers and deal with forms and banks
and all that kind of stuff and it's a
hassle so you know centralized money
exchange is a hassle decentralized is a
lot easier a lot more efficient even
though it's over collateralized for the
most part it's still a better way to do
it so i'm a big fan um
but you know the only
qualification to that that i'll give you
is that d5
you know i said on stage you know one of
my favorite warren buffett sayings is
first there's the innovators then
there's the imitators then there's the
idiots right d5 was a great innovation
then there was a lot of invitation and
you're seeing it jump from chain to
chain to chain right um now you're
starting to get the idiots who are
trying to you know add one feature or
this feature or that feature so you've
got to be careful so d5
you know where you've done you know
dyorn where you've done your homework
and you know it it's
it's
strong uh is great i think there's a
real opportunity one of your favorite
projects in d5 at the moment i don't
know if i have any favorites per se i
use ave a lot um
[Music]
you know
i i learned early on just chasing yield
doesn't really work um
so rather than chasing you i chase
stability
apart from defy cuban also talks at
length about nft
he explains that the biggest challenge
with the tokens which he refers to as
collectibles is creating a value
proposition for them cuban and his
mavericks have been able to conquer this
challenge by offering free nft with game
tickets thereby attaching great value to
them
cuban who has 80 of his non-shark tank
investments in crypto also believes the
industry still has some things to figure
out before creators can truly benefit
from selling their pieces as digital
assets here is mark cuban on
non-fungible tokens and how they can be
beneficial to creators
there's certainly value in nfts um but
again nft is more of proof of concept
for smart contracts and so like at the
mavericks we give away nfts to people
who actually come to the games and we
try and so they're free if you actually
attend the game you got to scan in and
and when you scan in your regular ticket
you get a free nft one per account and
that's led to people collecting them
which has created the value which in
some cases the value of the end of the
free nft you get is
of more value and they're sold to more
than the price for the ticket they paid
and so trying to create um
a value proposition for nfts right now
is the biggest challenge but really nfts
are the way we're seeing them now nfts
are collectibles right and
um you know collectibles are
collectibles there's things i collect
and nfts and physical collectibles i
just think nfts are a better
implementation of physical of
collectibles than physical nfts for
creators are amazing right because they
can keep on getting paid over and over
again if they build enough of community
nfts as
um money raising propositions like
fractionalization for real estate
there's still a lot of questions there
on the value proposition there um
it really just depends on the
application but that's normal in any
industry right where you go from okay
there's a lot of pain in 2017 2018 so
now there's a lot of experimentation and
you're starting to see some of the wins
that are are coming out you know board
ape and others and then you're starting
to see other applications using nfts
that are non-collectible ones like we
use for for tickets or whatever it may
be and there'll be more of those but you
know
smart contracts can do
a lot of things and you're just going to
see more applications in what would be
considered most controversial in many
quarters human also declares that he
sees nothing special with bitcoin
instead he prefers ethereum and polygon
because of their use cases the
billionaire also believes the issue of
high transaction fees on the ethereum
network will soon be resolved
with out of the way cuban believes the
network will do better than bitcoin
listen to cubans take on ethereum
bitcoin and polygon
ethereum and polygon that i bought a lot
of um you can start to see the utility
you're starting to see more and more
applications pop up there and we'll see
what happens with these 2.0 in terms you
know in terms of um fees gas fees and i
think polydon's done a great job and
you've got other blockchains trying to
do the same thing but all the
blockchains are kind of in a death war
right trying to get users in
applications and
i think
whoever comes up with applications where
just somebody walking down the street in
miami can say oh yeah i use that
just like you know instagram it was at
the beginning what the hell is instagram
then everybody got it went viral right
we haven't gotten that first viral
mainstream um crypto based application
yet we will that's what i'm looking for
in terms of of investments
you mentioned ethereum and you mentioned
polygon which are both ethereum right
right right right right you look at
other blockchains you look at solana and
avalanche and yeah i look at all of them
right but i don't see i mean they're
start they're trying to build
development developer bases but i see a
lot of me too stuff
so not only does the billionaire like
ethereum he is still waiting for an
instagram like blockchain project
something big enough that billions of
people around the world will have in use
for cuban this would provide a perfect
investment opportunity what are your
thoughts on cubans preferences do you
share similar views with a billionaire
and shark tank investor please leave
your comments in the comments section
below
if you are yet to do so please give this
video a thumbs up and subscribe to their
channel thanks for watching
you